most people may not be familiar with
gallium or germanium but these metals
are crucial for the development of
products such as semiconductors solar
panels electric vehicles and smartphones
China is the world's biggest supplier of
these raw materials and their export
will soon be controlled from the
beginning of August firms will need to
apply for permits and Supply information
about their intended use to gain access
Beijing says the new restriction will
protect China's national security
China has always been committed to
maintaining the security and stability
of the Global Production and supply
chain it's a common International
practice for the Chinese government to
impose export controls on relevant items
in accordance with the law without
targeting any specific country
the move is expected to disrupt Global
Supply chains and is being seen as a
response to wide-ranging high-tech
export controls imposed on Chinese
technology firms by the United States
it also comes days after the Dutch
government imposed similar restrictions
on the sale of crucial chip making
equipment
the U.S and the Netherlands are among
major importers of Chinese gallium and
germanium I think the first audience of
course are those who are making these
kinds of decisions which is to say look
um
everybody holds cards and we can all
play this game the cost of these raw
materials has surged though South Korea
and Taiwan have downplayed the impact of
the regulation on their phones some
analysts fear this move will provoke
further similar measures between Beijing
and Washington during his visit to
Beijing last month U.S Secretary of
State Anthony blinken defended U.S
controls as security related and denied
Washington was trying to contain China
Beijing has accused the U.S of
encirclement and suppression
U.S treasury secretary Janet Yellen is
expected in Beijing this week for a trip
aimed at further stabilizing
deteriorating ties trade and economic
cooperation are atop the agenda and it's
likely Beijing will use the control of
gallium and germanium as a bargaining
chip in its negotiations Katrina
altazira Beijing
to Thailand now with the newly elected